Caroline côté bonsoir
bonsoir oui c'est toute une aventure que
je viens de vivre je crois que je voyais
cette aventure là comme quelque chose de
possible je n'avais pas envisagé tous
les défis et je suis bien contente de
revenir le ça fait deux jours que je
suis revenu sur la petite ville de Punta
rez au Chili là vous vous reposer au
Chili sur la pointe du Chili qui est la
plus proche du pôle sud d'une certaine
façon quand on a demandé en 1924 à
George Mallory en alpiniste pourquoi il
voulait aller au sommet de l'Everest il
a répondu parce que c'est là tout
simplement qu'est-ce qui vous motiver
d'aller au pôle Sud et d'aller le plus
vite que tous les autres avant vous
déjà l'Antarctique allait là-bas on se
rend compte que c'est un lieu qui est
très hostile c'est un milieu où on va
facilement chercher ce qui est en nous
on va voir qui on est vraiment le fait
de le faire c'est le thermos aussi
c'était un défi que je voulais me lancer
quand est-ce que dans la vie on a
l'opportunité de faire ça de se
retrouver seul pendant
30 jours ou plus et ça m'impressionné ça
m'a étonné et c'est pas nécessairement
quelque chose que je referai parce que
de jamais avoir de gens autour de nous
pour nous nous appuyer ou nous dire
pourquoi parle un peu plus loin c'est ça
a été un bon défi justement d'être seul
racontez-moi bon vous partez là ça a
duré 34 jours alors vous partez là
qu'est-ce qui devient jour après jour le
plus difficile que c'est tout simplement
le froid
c'est c'est sûr que le froid fait en
sorte que le défi se complique qu'à
chaque jour donc on part à une
un niveau très bas près de près de la
mer donc on a des températures d'environ
moins 13 - 14 degrés et plus on avance
plus on avance on se rend à des
températures qui avaient les moins 30
degrés vers la fin au poste j'avais des
moins 34 et ouvrir la porte de sa petite
tente le matin c'est plus difficile
plus le vent qui est assez constant et
qui arrive en pleine face du Sud c'est
le défi principal ensuite il y a le fait
de savoir que tout mon équipement il
faut que je fasse vraiment attention
parce que c'est tout ce que j'ai mon
traîneau en fait c'est ma demeure c'est
ce que j'amène d'une journée à l'autre
plus proche du port les il faut que je
fasse attention à ce que à ce que
j'apporte avec moi pour en prendre soin
aussi
racontez-nous à quel moment vraiment les
embûches ou la hauteur du défi tout
simplement
on fait en sorte que mon année vous a
dit peut-être je serais pas capable à
quel moment vous êtes dit oh là là j'ai
embarqué dans quelque chose qui est
peut-être plus difficile que je croyais
encore
déjà chaque jour de faire 35 km environ
c'est un bon défi
le total du pas que j'avais avec moi
c'était environ 60 kg et je devais le
traîner
donc chaque jour je me demandais ça
allait être possible d'aller plus loin
avec c'est sur le vent et ça se trouve
des espèces d'information glacées
énormes et la température qui va être je
dirais que au milieu de l'aventure c'est
environ vers les fêtes je me sentais
triste je voyais devant moi qui me
restait encore 15 jours à donner toute
mon énergie puis c'est à ce moment-là
que je me suis dit ok bah de toute façon
je suis là j'ai la chance d'être en
Antarctique j'ai la chance de vivre ça
pourquoi pas y aller à fond et donner
tout ce que j'ai et finalement ben j'ai
su que mon conjoint allait m'attendre au
pôle sud puis j'ai vu son avion qui
passait pour aller me rejoindre donc ça
m'a donné le goût de continuer testament
puis c'est là où j'ai redoué redoublé
d'efforts jusqu'à l'arrivée
parlez moi du défi technique vous avez
parlé du nombre de kilos que vous aviez
dû être transporté si jamais une
fixation devait céder vous en aviez
d'autres avis du matériel vous avez il y
a plein de défis techniques de matériel
ou si vous devez avoir
exactement
en fait c'est ce qui s'est produit mon
ski a brisé la fixation s'est détachée
il faut devenir un peu réparateur ou
technicien de tout son équipement
j'avais de la bonne colle on s'entend
aussi que le fameux docteur et on en
apporte beaucoup sur le terrain sinon
le réseau il fallait que j'en prenne
soin j'ai eu deux problèmes mon panneau
solaire brisé et mon ski c'est des
choses que j'ai dû réparer mais vu que
j'essaie de voyager tellement léger pour
avoir le moins de poids possible pour
aller plus vite j'ai seulement une
paresse qui j'ai seulement
un réseau par exemple et tout ça fait en
sorte que c'est très stressant de savoir
si ça veut durer jusqu'au bout de
l'aventure évidemment
vous ne vous ne rencontrez évidemment
personne c'est vaccentir mais vous
rencontrez aucun animal ou qu'une vie
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui a
bougé pendant les 34 jours
incroyable on crisse vraiment avec sa
tête là très seul la bosse c'est blanc
et c'est le soleil qui est présent avec
nous durant toute la journée qui fait un
tour complet parce qu'il y a pas de nuit
donc on voit le soleil à droite et
ensuite ça se déplace à gauche c'est un
terminal pour ceux qui aiment la nuit il
y en a aucune là-bas j'ai je suis
arrivée ici puis c'est là où j'ai enfin
vu le ciel noir mais aucun animal
puisqu'on est un peu trop haut j'ai pas
vu d'oiseau et vraiment rien vivant là
jusqu'à l'arrivée au pôle
alors vous avez dit c'est rare qu'on se
retrouve avec soi-même pendant 30 jours
et plus en plus vous aviez des défis
quotidiens qu'est-ce que vous avez
découvert de vous
ça il faut que je fasse encore un bon un
bon constat dans les jours c'est sûr
qu'une force intérieure qui vient avec
l'aventure que je viens de vivre
si on dit souvent
l'ego m'a permis d'aller plus loin puis
dans mon aventure c'est ce qui s'est
passé au jour 3 là
ce qui m'a permis d'aller plus loin
c'est pas nécessairement le fait de dire
que je voulais faire cette grande
expédition là mais c'est vraiment les
gens que j'aime autour de moi qui me
permettait de d'avoir le courage de
continuer et en terminant deux questions
qu'est-ce que vous allez il y aura un
film il y aura qu'est-ce qu'il y aura
quel est le débouché documentaire de
votre mission là
alors malheureusement j'ai pas pu
prendre beaucoup d'images de ce beau
défilé parce que j'étais dans un effort
constant
j'ai quelques vidéos que je vais je vais
présenter sous peu mais c'est minime
comparé au documentaire que je fais
habituellement sur d'autres expéditions
donc un livre et certainement un
baladeau qui va venir avec cette
épreuve-là qui j'espère va pouvoir
mettre les gens dans le bain dans
l'ambiance de ce que j'ai vécu en
Antarctique le dépassement à ce
niveau-là à ces niveaux là est-ce que ça
implique que vous êtes condamné à
trouver un autre défi ensuite que vous
pouvez pas arrêter
évidemment
le domaine de l'aventure c'est un peu ça
c'est pour ces raisons là que j'ai
toujours envie de continuer parce que on
fait des apprentissages à chaque
expédition sur qui on est vraiment et
bon je peux dire que quand je suis
arrivé au pôle j'ai dit à Vincent mon
conjoint que c'était terminé que
j'allais passer à autre chose que
j'allais rester pendant la maison donc
c'est ce qui s'est passé par contre plus
j'avais de sommeil accumulé donc plus je
pouvais me reposer ici en ville je suis
déjà en train de planifier quelques
autres aventures
mais faut rester prudent il faut rester
prudent faut parler trop loin aussi
cette expédition là m'a pris beaucoup
d'énergie donc le repos fait partie
aussi de
du système de commande très bien
Caroline côté c'est un exemple en tout
cas pour beaucoup de gens se dépassement
là le goût de l'aventure le goût d'aller
dehors le goût de découvrir le goût de
se pousser aux limites merci beaucoup de
nous avoir parlé du Chili ce soir
merci beaucoup à vous bonne fin de
soirée tout le monde